at mar-a-lago the president is not
taking a holiday break from Twitter
he's tweeted several times complaining
about his impeachment he accuses House
Democrats of stall tactics even after
one Senate Republican expressed her
reservations chip Reid is traveling with
the president in Florida chip where did
things stand right now well the latest
news is that Republican senator Lisa
Murkowski has criticized Republican
leader Mitch McConnell and that means
that the Democrats have some hope that
there might be witnesses at the Senate
trial we will continue to push for rules
that give us witnesses and documents
that is the key Democratic Senator
Richard Blumenthal who would be one of
100 Senate jurors in the president's
Senate impeachment trial supports House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi decision to
withhold the articles of impeachment
until Democrats can ensure a fair
process Mitch McConnell is sabotaging
this proceeding
Alaska Republican senator Lisa Murkowski
says she was disturbed by these comments
by Republican leader Mitch McConnell I'm
gonna coordinate with the president's
lawyers so there won't be any difference
between us on how to do this some House
Democrats are concerned about
Republicans impartiality some of them
have decided already that they will not
be impartial they actually have to take
an oath to say they will be impartial
the game in the house was rigged it was
rigged as a carnival ring toss
but Republican Senator John Kennedy said
it was the house process that was unfair
and once the Senate to act differently I
want people to walk away saying the
Senate gave everyone due process and an
opportunity to be heard because they
can't say that now even if some
Republicans vote with the Democrats on
having witnesses that certainly does not
necessarily mean that they'll vote with
the Democrats on removing the president
from office and keep in mind removing
him from office takes a two-thirds vote
of the Senate and that at this point
looks extremely unlikely Dana all right
chip thank you
you